[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my gosh you're so cool thanks man oh
my gosh i have help
i'm not this cool by myself um okay well
that kind of brings me right back to
when um i i saw you in let's talk about
a few of your projects if you don't mind
um
deadpool oh yeah okay okay you're so hot
and cool in that thank you can you fly
on the wall moments from deadpool
um
i will say
the second film um i shot all of my
scenes underwater
and that never made it in the movie and
i i was
when i tell you in a panic like i was
panicked the entire time this is not i
don't scuba dive i don't do well and it
was like it was as if like you know like
it was probably another 10 feet above
the ceiling here and when you're like
you know i think this was the the word
for i need air and then this is the word
for get me out of here
i was always doing this and they'd like
okay they'd have to like strap de-strap
me from because they're weighted i'm
sure you're weighing it down that you're
not floating up it's terrifying um okay
homeland
oh my god first of all
kudos to you you've got mandy patek and
claire danes damian lewis like everyone
doing their thing and you come in there
with your moxie and just meet the moment
thank you they shot the pilot with
somebody else unfortunately and it
didn't work out for whatever reason as
the mom and i i got the role and came in
already to
you know a pretty gelled
cast and
um the kids they were like kind of
putting me through the ringer a little
bit the kids they were like so what's
your name
uh-huh you think you can just come in
here and be our mom now okay
let's see by the end of that day we were
besties all right give me a fly on the
wall moment from the amazing show gotha
oh wow
that show
um has a real special place in my heart
of course because it's right by my
husband
uh and i you know our we all we shot
together for five years we became a real
family um i had a baby
that's him
he wrote um
the last episode that we ever shot and
it was a scene where the very very last
thing we shot after five years was our
marriage scene our characters getting
married
and it was i'm gonna start crying
thinking about it but he like he wrote
this beautiful speech that harvey gave
that was very um you know sort of
personal to us and had beat moments that
really resonated with our personal life
that's so much even better than fly on
the wall okay
tell me
about endgame
uh yeah it's i'm so thrilled with how uh
they've been supporting the show uh i
don't think you can be a human in any
city in the united states right now
without seeing it
it's the end game with like you're
sexy um it's a joke in my family bow to
the queen now um
it's so i play elena federova who is an
international arms dealer
who uh has orchestrated getting arrested
essentially so she can set in motion
with a fabulous carolina herrera dress
that i found myself it's and it doesn't
wrinkle which is really impressive no it
doesn't i didn't notice that it doesn't
wrinkle i kept watching i was like it's
gonna wrinkle it's gonna no it's not
wrinkling no i'm not wearing
for
three or four days straight i only took
it off at lunch and they only pressed it
once in the day anyway to to go on about
what the show is about um she gets
captured and i even though my means of
going about things are potentially
illegal and a little questionable what i
want is justice and truth and revenge
for what happened to my family which was
orchestrated somehow by the us
government which you'll come to find i'm
probably giving out a lot of secrets i
should no this is so good i'm sorry to
say it sounds sick but everybody loves
revenge yes they do yes
it's healthy it's a healthy dose it's so
true
um
well i happen to be looking at your
instagram page um i hope that's okay i'm
glad cyber's talking you there for the
looking okay good
um well we wanted to just do a little
quick deep dive with you and see um if
we could ask you some rapid fire
questions that we've got from your
profile okay all right you call yourself
a wine drinker late night thinker what's
the best idea you've ever had while
drinking wine at night
having a third kid
okay perfect parlay with three kids
under the age of ten what is the best
parenting advice you've ever gotten
just try to be good enough
don't try to be perfect
[Applause]
as a brazilian native what is your first
stop when you go back to visit
um i go to these little kiosks that sell
they have like they're lined with fruits
um and you just make up a juice
combination and a grilled cheese
sandwich the grilled cheese the grilled
cheese they're the best flat it's the
best the best grilled cheese ever um
well thank you so much marina watch the
end game monday nights on nbc
and as usual we'll be cheering you on
and admiring everything you do thank you
so much we'll be right back
[Music]